Transcriber: Saliha Karatepeli
Gözden geçirme: Nihal Aksakal
Hello!
Şimdi, siber güvenlik konuşmadan önce
merak ettiğim bir konu var arkadaşlar.
Şimdi herkes gözü kapatsın,
bir ressam hayal etsin istiyorum.
Tamam mı?
Harbiden kapatın lütfen, görüyoruz.
Çünkü yeteri kadar ışık var,
kapatmadığınızı görüyorum.
Bir ressam hayal edin.
Resim çizerken ya da tuvalin
karşısında bir şey yaparken
nasıl biri canlanıyor gözünüzde?
Buna tabii ki de tek tek cevap alma
imkânım olmayacak benim amma velakin
benim bu soruya, bu slaytı dün akşam
hazırlarken verdiğim cevap Bob Ross.
Kaç kişi benzer bir görüntü canlandırdı?
Hemen hemen salonun tamamı.
Rahmetliyi de anmış olduk böylece.
Çocukluğunda çok izlerdim TRT’de.
Neden aynı şeyi görüyoruz biliyor musunuz?
Çünkü böyle bir imge
var kafamızda, değil mi?
Ressam dediğin tuvalin karşısındadır.
Resim çizer, elinde de palet vardır.
Nasıl bir insan dediğimizde, hepimiz
böyle sakallı, kıvırcık birini hatırlıyor.
Çünkü bu bilgi bizim
beynimizin içerisinde var.
Güzel.
Çok sevdim.
Katılım da harika.
Benzer bir şeyi yapacağız ama yapmadan
önce sizlere minik bir hikâye anlatacağım.
2006 yılının yedinci ayının 14′ü
olması lazım, değil mi?
Saat 12:54:02′de
“goping.com” isimli bir web sitesinin
ana sayfası değiştirildi.
Biz buna biliyorsunuz ki
web sitelerinin yaşadığı
bir hacking saldırısı adını veriyoruz.
Tam bu bahsettiğim tarihten sonraki
bir sene boyunca dünya genelinde,
envai çeşit farklı ülkede,
beş yüz bine yakın
web sitesinde aynı yazı yazdı.
Bir sene sonra da bir daha
hiçbir web sitesine bu Hacker’ın
böyle bir saldırı
organize etmediğini gördük.
Şimdi kapatın gözleri.
Soru aynı.
Bu bir sene boyunca bu kadar büyük suçlar
işleyen bir Hacker nasıl biridir?
Ya betimlemeye çalışın.
Bunu istiyorum sizden.
Cinsiyeti nedir?
Nasıl bir ortamda yapıyordur?
Bu aktivite, 12:54, gözümde canlansın.
İçinizden sormayın “P.M mi A.M mi?“.
Siz seçin, nasıl bir ortam?
Çok isterdim böyle sizden
mikrofonla cevaplar alabilmek
ama herkes gözünü açsın.
Bence birçok kişi böyle
bir şey hayal ediyor.
Kaç kişi üç aşağı beş yukarı
bunu hayal etti?
Güzel.
Kaç kişi Mr. Robot’u izledi?
Aynı kişiler el kaldırıyor.
Çünkü Hollywood’dan gördüğümüz
böyle bir şey var bizim
hayatımızda, değil mi?
Hacker dediğin siyah giyer.
Kötü insandır.
Soru işareti, bilmiyoruz.
İyi miyiz, kötü müyüz?
Kötü şeyler yapar, değil mi?
Düşündüğümüz şey bu.
O tarihlerde bu aktiviteyi
gerçekleştiren kişinin,
ben fotoğrafını buldum arkadaşlar.
15 yaşında bir oğlan, yanında
kendisinden 9 yaş küçük kız kardeşi var.
Abisinin ne yaptığına dair
hiçbir fikri yok.
Size yemin ederim ki abisinin de
ne yaptığına dair hiçbir fikri yok.
Ama bu adamın neler yaptığını
anlatıyoruz, değil mi?
Kaç kişi gerçekten böyle bir resmin
çıkmasını bekliyordu, el kaldırsın.
İki, üç, süper.
Hanginiz Siber Güvenlik ile ilgileniyor?
Çıkışta.
Gelin konuşalım.
Şimdi kafamızda bir imaj var.
Yani biz günün sonunda,
hani Hacker dediğimiz zaman
gördüğümüz şey  kötü bir imaj.
Google’a Hacker kelimesini
yazdığında bunlar çıkıyor.
Hepinizin betimlediği şey.
Az önceki resimdeki o genç çocuğun
ben olduğu da aşikâr değil mi?
Ben,
o zamanlarla ilgili böyle
bazı sorular  soruyorum kendime.
Kötü insan olarak
görüyoruz Hacker’ları.
Evet ama o zamanlara dair bir
soru soruyorum kendime.
Çok basit bir soru,
bence siz de bana soruyorsunuzdur
ya da o yıllarda bilseniz
sorardınız: Neden?
Yani, niye?
Çok basit bir soru, değil mi?
Şimdi ben bu soruya o zamanlar,
tabii daha bıngıldağı kapanmamış
bir gencecik oğlansın,
tabii ki de buna cevap veremiyorsun.
Ama o zamana dair hatırladığım
bazı duygularım var.
Birinci duygu çok basit bir şey.
Çünkü yapabiliyordum.
Bir şey yapabiliyor olmak, yapmak için
yeterli bir sebep olabilir hayatta.
İki, çok zevkliydi.
Yani-
Bilmem zevk aldığınız bir şeyi yapmayı
hayatta herkes ister, değil mi?
Hani, bu hep böyledir?
Üç, ego.
Kaç kişi Hacker’ların
egolu olduğunu düşünüyor?
Birçok kişi, değil mi?
Ben de gerçekten bu duygu üzerine
bir iki kelam söylemek istiyorum sizlere.
İşin içerisinde ego var.
Yani bir sene içerisinde yarım milyona
yakın web sitesine zarar veriyorsun.
Suç işliyorsun ki suç algısını
birazdan konuşacağız
ve o tanımadığın insanlar
seni takip ediyor.
Günümüzün sosyal medyası gibi.
Seni biliyorlar.
O yıllarda tabii ki de sosyal medya
günümüzdeki gibi değil.
Seni takip ediyorlar ve yaptıklarının
karşılığında da repütasyon alıyorsun.
Mükemmel bir ego tatmin yöntemi.
Bu üç şey, bir insanın
suç işlemesi için
yeterli olabiliyormuş demek ki.
Ben 2000... Bahsettim ya işte
bir senelik bir zaman dilimi.
Onun sonunda,
o serüvende bir gün anladım.
Ben bu siyah maskeyi
çıkaracağım hayatımdan.
Yani kötü bir şey yapan bir
insan olmak istemiyorum.
Onu zaman içerisinde öğreniyorsun.
Yaptığının kötü bir şey
olduğunu algılıyorsun
ki o yıllarda siber suç
diye bir şey yok.
Evet, günümüzde var,
başka problemleri var.
Ayrı konu ama yaptığı şeyin suç
olduğuna dair de bir hissiyat yok.
Tamamiyle de zahiri dünyada yaşıyorsun,
yani gördün çocuğu işte.
Tamam mı, orada ergen oturuyor yani.
Tamamiyle sanal dünyada
ailesinin ne yaptığına dair haberi yok.
Yanında da kardeşi bakıyor
ne yapıyor bu çocuk diye.
Onun orada kendi sanal bir dünyası var
ve sanal dünyada suç işlerken
hiçbir zaman suç işliyormuşsunuz
gibi hissedilmiyor.
Bugün, şimdi soracağım da
hiç kimse el kaldırmaz.
Yani kaç kişinin fake account’u var,
sosyal medyada?
Dürüstçe kaldırın.
Var, değil mi?
Çünkü neden var, kolay.
Kolay.
Bugün mesela siber zorbalık
diye bir kelime var,
onun üzerine konuşmayacağım
ama çıkıp birine
siber zorbalık yapmak çok kolay.
Bugün girin internete,
biri benim adıma account açıp
hepinize küfür edebilir.
Kolay ve bu kolay olduğu şeyi yapmak da,
insan yaparken suçu hissetmiyor.
İnsanoğlu biraz şöyle bir şey...
Hacking dünyası özelinde konuşabilirim
tabii ki bu alanı da.
Şöyle bir şey yani,
sonuçlarıyla yüzleşmeden
suçun suç olduğunu
algılamadığın bir dünya.
Ya biri sana bunu öğretecek
ya da sen kendin öğreneceksin hayatta.
Hani, kendin öğreniyorsan hayatta
genellikle zaten çok geçmiş olsun
dediğimiz arkadaşlar oluyor.
Yani yanlış bir yol.
Bunu altını çizerek
konuşmak istiyorum
çünkü zahiri yani
gerçek değil gibi hiçbir şey.
Yani bir o kadar da gerçek ama hani.
Orada binlerce dolar para harcanmış
bambaşka bir ülkedeki bir web sitesini
vurup kırıp geçiyorsun.
Hani verdiğin zararı hissetmiyorsun bile.
Gülüyorsun, ego tatmin oluyor dediğim.
Ben 2007 yılının sonunda
bu durumu fark ettim
ve hayatımın son 14 yılını arkadaşlar
güvenlik açıkladıklarını
Hacker’lardan önce bulmaya adadım.
Bu 14 yıllık serüvenin içerisinde
fark ettim ki bunu ben tek başıma yapamam.
O zaman başka insanlar var.
O zaman bildiklerimi anlatmalıyım.
Hasbelkader de binlerce insanın
hoca dediği bir insan
olmaya başladım hayatta.
Çünkü bildiklerimi öğretiyorum insanlara.
Bu da işin içerisindeki o bahsettiğim
dürtüler var ya tatmin olma duygusu işte,
onu tatmin etmeye başlıyor
hayatınızda bir yerde
ve şöyle bir noktaya geliyorum.
Hacker’lar gerçekten kötü insanlar
olarak mı algılanmalı?
Bu algı değişmeli mi?
Çünkü bugün burada ben sizin
karşınızda konuşuyorum.
Belki aramızda başka insanlar da var.
Kesin vardır hani.
Maskelerin renkleri farklı.
Bu insanların kimisi beyaz maskeli,
diğeri siyah maskeli
ama bu maskeyi çıkarttığında
ortak özellikler
görmeye başlıyorsun insanlarda.
Evet, Hacker kelimesi ortak bir kelime.
Ama niyet diye bir kavram
girmeye başlıyor.
Duyduğunuz beyaz şapkalı hacker,
siyah şapkalı hacker algısını
işin içerisine koymaya başlıyoruz.
Hacker dediğimizde kötü bir imaj var.
Sordum siz el kaldırdınız, okey.
Hiç kimsenin aklına şey gelmiyor:
Bunlar aslında aynı insanlar.
O zaman niyet dediğimiz bir konu
ortaya çıkmaya başlıyor
ve hani şöyle bir şeyi sorgulamaya
başlıyorum ben hayatın içerisinde.
Peki, güzel, bu insanların niyetlerinden
bağımsız baktığımızda
nasıl kişiler görmeliyiz,
Hacker’lar nedir?
Kendimden nacizane yola çıkarsam
ve bu 14 yıl içerisinde
tanıştığım insanlara baktığımda
çok güzel ortak bir özellik görüyorum.
Obsesiflik.
Bir obsesiflik var
işin içerisinde, bir takıntı.
Çocukluğumda bilgisayardan
beni ayıramadılar.
Yani, ayıramadılar.
Uzun hikayeler girmeyelim, o kablolar
saklanır bulunur edilir hani.
Bunu izleyen bu anda aramızda olan
genç arkadaşlarda bile
çok fazla Valorant oynadın,
derslere çalışmadım hikâyeleri.
Ama beni ayıramadılar işin içerisinden,
obsesifçe bağlıyım buna.
Buna başka bir şekilde de açıklayamıyorum
ve tanıştığım insanların hepsi de böyle.
Yani hayatımın son 14 yılını,
hep gözünüzde şu canlansın.
Hani 30 saattir ayaktasınız.
Hani on beşinci kahveyi içiyorsunuz.
Sabah saat 5
ve bir güvenlik açığı arıyorsunuz.
Bulmadan uyuyamazsın.
O bulmadan hayat devam edemez.
Bende böyle bir takıntı var hayatımda
ve bu alanda tanıştığım insanların
hemen hepsinde de aynı takıntıyı gördüm.
Güzel, Enter’a basıyorsun,
o güvenlik açığının varlığını görüyorsun
ve çalışıyor ya.
Artık uyuyabilirsin abi.
Ondan sonrası rahat.
Şimdi o Enter’a bastıktan sonra
ne yapacağın da
maskenin rengini belirliyor hayatta işte.
O noktaya kadar her şey
aynı aslına bakarsanız yani.
Ne yapacaksın?
Bu sefer de şöyle bir yaklaşım
çıkıyor ortaya, şöyle bir fikir var yani.
Belki de hepimizin hayatını çok ciddi
derecede etkileyecek,
kritik, hassas verilerinizin ifşasına
sebep olacak bir güvenlik açığı buldunuz.
Hepiniz şu anda bu açığı
bildiğinizi düşünün,
sizden başka kimse bilmiyor.
Bu zafiyeti ben sömürerek bu bilgilere
elde eder, bakarım,
merak ederim diyenler el kaldırsın.
Kaldır, dürüst ol.
Fake account olanlar el kaldırıyor.
Ben anlıyorum pattern’i.
Peki ilgili merciye bildirmek
isterim diyenler?
Daha fazla kişi görüyorum.
Çünkü çok basit bir konu var.
Burada çok tehlikeli bir durum var
ve bunun kapatılması lazım.
Evet, ben hayatımın son 14 yılını
bu şekilde yaşıyorum
ama bu sefer başka sorunlar
hayatta çıkmaya başlıyor yani.
Evet, ben beyaz şapkalı Hacker’ım
dediğimiz olgu içerisine girdin.
Aynı şeyleri yapıyorsun, aynı hazla,
aynı keyfi yaşamaya
hayatta devam etmektesin
ve belki de birçok insanın hayatında
çok hassas bir şeye sebep olabilecek
güvenlik açığı buldun
ve yapmak istediğin şey bunu çözmek.
Ne yapacaksın?
Gidip ilgili merciyi bulup
bildirmen lazım, değil mi?
O zaman başka sorunlar
çıkmaya başlıyor hayatında.
Koskoca bir kurum.
Kimi bulacaksın?
Müşteri hizmetlerini mi arayacaksın?
Aradım IT’ye bağlanmaya çalışıyorsun.
Günlerce uğraşırsın, hayatım, bununla
günlerce uğraşmakla geçti.
Bu tür şeylerle geçmişti
ve bir şekilde başardın
tüm bunların hepsini
ve güvenlik zafiyetini bildirdin.
Karşılığında ne göreceksiniz?
Maalesef ve maalesef 10 vakanın
8′inde dava ediliyorsun.
Niyet, hani?
Ben iyi bir şey yapıyorum.
Bu yaklaşımın kötü olduğunu
düşünen bence yoktur.
Yani en azından
ben düşünmüyorum, değil mi?
Çünkü gerçek saldırganlar bunu bulup
sömürdüklerinde ciddi sorunlar yaşanacak.
Ben buna engel olmak istiyorum
ama 10 vakanın 8′inde dava ediliyor
bu yaklaşımın içerisinde olan insanlar
ve hiçbir kötü niyetleri de yok.
Dava edilme sebepleri de
bizden izin almadan bizim sistemlerimizde
nasıl bir güvenlik açığı bulabilirsin?
Sen suç işledin, bu suç mu?
Soru işareti.
Baktığımda yazılı olan şeye evet.
Bilişim Suçları Yasası açısından
baktığımda suça girebiliyor
ama ben size başka bir örnek vereyim.
Bu benim kafamda her seferinde
düşündüğüm bir soru.
Ya sokaktasın, yürüyorsun,
bir tane bir şiddet olayı gördün.
Biri bıçak çekmiş birinin
üstüne yürüyecek.
Yani ne yaparsın, buna reaksiyon gösterip
o suçun işlenmesine,
o kişinin başına o zararın gelmesine
engel olmak isteyen insanlar
hasbelkader güvenlik kamerasından
görüntülendi ise
ana haber bültenlerinde
izleyip duygulanıyoruz.
Ben gerçekten de duygulanıyorum,
mükemmel bir şey, değil mi?
Tanımadığınız bir insanın başına kötü
bir şey gelmesini engelliyorsunuz.
Hatta yasal düzlemde de gördüğünüz
suçu raporlamak zorundasınız.
Bildirmeniz gerekiyor, günün sonunda.
Şimdi az önceki vakayla bunun
arasında bir fark var mı ?
Dünya artık dijital bir dünya.
Yani suç işlenebilecek bir durum
görüyorsun ve bunun giderilmesi-
Ben o paradoksu çözemedim hayatımda.
Yani benim baktığım açı her zaman,
burada suça yaklaşımın
ve bu olaylara bakış açılarının
biraz dünyada
değişmesi gerektiğine inanıyorum.
Çünkü çok basit bir tane soru var,
günün sonunda.
Hepimiz telefon kullanıyoruz.
Hepimiz siber saldırıların yaşandığını
biliyoruz ve bu olay yirmi yıldır var.
Her sene ve her sene siber saldırıların
arttığını duyuyoruz değil mi?
Sağdan, soldan, medyadan yani bugün
devlet başkanları siber güvenlik
kapsamında toplantı yapıyorlar.
Ben 2006 yılında güvenlikle
uğraşıyorum dediğimde,
yani insanlar siberi hatırlamıyor iken
aradan geçen 15 senede
bu kadar önemli bir noktaya
gelmiş durumdayız.
Ama şöyle bir sorun var ortada,
kötü niyetli kişiler her zaman var
ve her zaman olacak
ve biz bu mücadeleyi ne yapacağız?
Çünkü 15 yıldır kötü kişilerin
sayısı artmakta.
Yaşanan vaka sayıları artmakta
ve biz ne yapıyoruz?
Antivirüs yüklemeye devam mı edeceğiz?
Antivirüs sorunu çözüyor olsaydı
zaten ben burada olmazdım hayatta.
Çözülmüş olurdu.
Kurumlar, firmalar her sene siber
güvenliğe ayırdıkları bütçeleri
daha da artırmaya,
daha da artırmaya devam ediyor.
Her sene artıyor olay.
Harcanan para artıyor, emek harcıyor,
siber suç daha da artıyor.
O zaman,
az önce de bu işin iyi niyetinde
olan insanların da
hayatını ve bakış açısını
anlattım sizlere.
Geriye aslında benim cevabını vermeyeceğim
ve herkesin düşünmesini istediğim
bir tane soru ortaya
çıkıyor arkadaşlar.
Siber uzayda, ki sınırları
olmayan bir dünya,
ben bugün burada,
şu anda rahat rahat konuşurken
Çin’deki bir kişinin
benim çalıştığım kurumda
bir siber saldırı
düzenliyor olma ihtimali var.
Sınırların olmadığı siber uzayda,
bu Hacker’larla kimler,
nasıl mücadele edecek?
Çok teşekkür ederim dinlediğiniz için.
Çok sağ olun.
(Alkışlar)